(gentle music)
- I think that he will probably be
further ahead in this exercise than I am
when it comes to questions about myself.
- I'm interested to see what she does
'cause she's a pretty humble person.
- [Host] Take a step
forward if you trust Hailee
to do your laundry.
Take a step forward if you
wouldn't change anything
on Hailee's face.
Step forward if you wish Hailee could see
how beautiful she was.
Take a step forward if
Isabel gives good advice.
Take a step forward if you think Isabel
has a beautiful body.
Take a step forward if you wish Isabel
could see how beautiful she was.
Take a step forward if
Vicky makes you laugh.
Take a step forward if you think Vicky
lights up the room.
Take a step forward if
you believe in Vicky.
Cesar gives good advice.
Take a step back if you wish Cesar
was capable of achieving his goals.
Take a step forward if
you believe in Cesar.
(soft piano)
- It should be okay, I
should just be able to like
walk forward if that's how I truly feel,
but there's a moment of
hesitation and then I just like,
don't move.
I think it's sort of
symptomatic of being in a
loving relationship where
you need that other person
to support you.
- I'm real, you know.
- [Isabel] Cesar.
- I thought I'd be more
confident, but it's just,
I guess the honesty
just came out, I guess.
I was being honest with myself.
Thank you for believing in me.
- Awe, of course I do.
- It's fair, right?
(laughing)
I don't know.
- I think it falls in line
with what I said earlier
about how I'm just, I'm
really hard on myself
all the time and I know that.
- To me, she's perfect in my eyes.
There's little things here
and there where you're like,
does she make silly
decisions where it's like,
I don't necessarily
see that as a negative.
(soft music)